The next major upgrade came
with Android 4.4 KitKat.
Which introduced the scenes and
transitions API.
To see what's going on behind the
scenes, let's look at a small example.
When I tap this button the OS
executes a transition and
needs to do a couple of things.
First, it needs to
capture the starting and
end state for every view in the scene.
And create an animator that will
interpolate between the starting
and end states.
So in this case the end state
is that the image is gone.
The starting state is that
the image is visible.
So here's the code to slide
a view off the top of the screen,
beginDelayedTransition takes a view
group and a transition type.
In this case it's the root view and
the slide transition.
Immediately after the call
to beginDelayedTransition,
transition calls capture start states.
Which indicated captures
the start save for
all views in the view group
before we've modified them.
After that's done we modify the elements
we want to change or transition.
When the frame is done, transition
manager calls capture end states,
which does, you guessed it,
stores the end states of all of
the views in the view group.
The transition calles creat animator
with the state and animator set and
executes it.
The STK comes with a bunch of
fabricated transitions listed here.
Be mindful that all of them aren't
supported on all versions of Android, so
if you require them you might
be excluding some users.